[Music]
is
God but uh for proof that Jesus was a
Muslim are you willing are you ready to
win 200 actually it's more than 200
because I'm adding 200 to the total so
it's actually 400 in your pocket today
if you can prove that Jesus was a Muslim
all right man a challenge accepted so uh
if if I win I want you to donate it to a
good cause like animal shelter or
something
all right
your choice you tell us the place to
donate it to and we'll both do it live
animal shelter near you bro I'll be
happy with that all right I'm going for
it man so uh prove Jesus is a Muslim uh
the word Muslim in my opinion means the
one who like uh um the one who submits
his work to God so the one who Works
according to God
right do you agree
yeah we do yep we'll go with that
definition
so I believe Jesus uh said uh uh I don't
do anything of my own self I only do
what the what my father has commanded me
can I ask him just one question before
you proceed with him Avery the question
that I would ask is the prophets of Baal
they truly believe that ball is the one
true God and they submitted their will
to ball can you say that those prophets
of ball are they Muslim
no bro because all is not the uh it's
not it's not the god of Abraham
oh okay so the god of Abraham is the god
that we're speaking about now would you
believe that this God
is uni personal of course right
um so I think we're going into the
Trinity I want to stay at the point that
Jesus submits his will to the father so
at that point he's Muslim he's Aslam or
he's solidity to the will of the father
go ahead Avery
I think that we're gonna go around the
same lines anyway
yeah I think that the next uh obvious
question would be is Allah the father
um let's say I have to put that a Muslim
is a person that submits his will to the
will of God and that's exactly what
Jesus did so well that's so again that's
that's why um that's why Chris Claus was
asking the question if
you know these prophets of ball they
submitted themselves to Baal and then
that's the one God that they submit to
and they worship are they Muslim and you
would say no because that's not the true
God that's a false god a false idea of
God that's not the true God the god of
Abraham right who has specific qualities
and specific characteristics that define
him so
if when we're looking at Jesus right
we're proving that Jesus is a Muslim
what you're doing is that you're proving
that Jesus submitted and worshiped and
taught about the same God that you as a
Muslim you believe and you submit to
right so the one true God or Jesus you
know as you said Jesus submitted to the
father
is the one true God the Father
yes that's in my opinion in my belief my
brother I believe the father that Jesus
is talking about is my Allah it's the
same the one and the thing that's what
Jesus says Elohim and my belief he's
saying he's talking about my God and
when Jesus worships that God and he's
telling me how to worship that God by
telling us our father that means
everyone's father you know what I'm
saying so okay no problem
it's the same God so when Jesus is
submitting submitting to that God he's
submitting in my opinion to the father
like uh you say a father in Arabic that
would be up but Allah has a different
word is he says
yeah it basically means to say oh no no
Lord and father are two different
meanings you can be someone's Lord but
not their father you um you can be a
father and a lord to the person but Lord
is not necessarily a father so we're
talking about the ultimate law that is
always yeah the ultimate Lord obviously
yes yes the ultimate Lord is definitely
god
um but now is is when you say that the
the ultimate Lord is is God would you
say that the ultimate father is God as
well
of course
every atom of course so would you so is
there somewhere in the Quran
that says that Allah is the father
so um I think I I don't have the
knowledge bro because okay it's not for
me to say something that I don't know
the exact knowledge of okay so it's all
right but what I do know is that uh so
not to confuse us uh we've got another
word
are two different things right one is
Lord one is father so a def the Quran
definitely calls Allah the Lord
definitely calls them Lord master and
things of this nature but it does not
call him father doesn't identify him as
the father
and the Quran says actually that in
Chapter 19 Verse 93
that none can come to him in heaven or
on earth except as a slave a servant
so you can't even come to him
metaphorically according to the Quran as
a as a son or daughter you can't you
can't address him as father you can only
address him as master and Lord
you know
so that that because because I don't
believe that God has Offspring God
doesn't doesn't like that I reproduce
but uh in in the spirit of of the
language when when we say father we mean
like a originator
where we all come from you know the the
cause the uncaused cause as we Muslims
like to say yeah
so so you you mentioned the verse um
where Jesus says the son can do
nothing of himself but he uh or doesn't
follow his will but he does what the
father does or what what the father
commands him right and so um
I wanna I wanna go to that context where
he mentions that it's John chapter five
it's a beautiful it's a beautiful verse
you mentioned I love that verse
um
and this is what it reads okay I'm gonna
read this to you because I think it's
fair that we have to and even when I'd
like to do this with the Quran I like to
I I like to read a verse in the context
that is being talked about right the
surrender the verses before and the
verses after to see what it's being said
right that's a fair approach right
okay
so here's the verse
there's John chapter 5 verse 19.
and Jesus put me on the big screen
oh yeah sure
whoops
all right so it says this it says so
Jesus said to them
truly truly I say to you the son can do
nothing of his own accord
but only what he sees the father doing
for whatever the father does
that the son does likewise
for the father loves the son and shows
him all that he himself is doing
and Greater Works than these will he
show him so that you may Marvel
for as the father raises the dead and
gives them life
so also the son gives life to whom he
Wills
for the father judges no one but has
given all judgment to the son that all
may honor the son just as they honor the
father
whoever does not honor the son does not
honor the father who sent him
so would do you believe thanks Chris do
you believe that this is that this type
of teaching
lines up with Islamic teaching that
Jesus is the son of the father who does
whatever the father does can do whatever
the father can do
um gives life to whomever he chooses
and is the one who judges the father
doesn't judge but it's the son who
judges
is that in line with uh Islam
it's a it's a great question my brother
no that's not in line with Islam so
this is what this is what's important
about this when it comes to this
conversation my friend is that
um and this is what I learned in this
conversation like this is what like when
I have this title I've seen this happen
where
um Muslims they they know some verses in
the Bible right they know some verses in
the Bible where Jesus clearly submits
himself to the father right and he's a
servant right he's sent by him he's a
servant he humbles himself before him
and things of this nature and they'll
pluck out a verse that says that but
ignore the verse that came prior or even
after or even like the rest of that
phrase because notice how when we read
the part that where it says the sun
could do nothing of himself
there's another part to that like that
sentence isn't done but what he sees the
father doing so whatever God does Jesus
says I do
you look that you look up that same
verse again but like in uh I use the
Bible Hub so in the Bible Hub you get
multiple readings yeah I got you I got
you
let's go to Bible Hub John chapter 5
verse 19.
and I like the old English of the King
James version yeah King James okay okay
you you like that old English for real I
love it man I love it it's poetic I'll
give it that but goodness yeah it's that
because the Quran is poetic as well the
Quran it's like a poem it's like a
challenge it challenges like the old
Poets of Arabia you know what I'm saying
so uh so that's why I like the old
English yeah for sure for sure okay the
old English is the word will as well
yep
so
um
you did you did you want to just see uh
19 or did you want to see all of it just
or just the verse 19. I won't bother you
with it I'll go look it up myself
all right no worries
so logic mostly like uh when you say we
pick and choose it's like uh when we
read the Bible we understand that uh
that
um Jesus is a prophet so we cling on to
that and like we ignore like the other
verses that say otherwise or that you
would you would bring up that would say
otherwise
Yeah well yeah yeah and I know I'm
learning man we are all learning bro
yeah that's true I I man I would
honestly um I would encourage you
because you seem like you you seem
genuine man and you seem pretty cool too
like I don't know what's going on today
we're pretty getting some pretty cool
Muslims up on the stage I would
encourage you bro and and whenever you
have time go through the Gospel of John
you know I'm not saying that you have to
believe in or anything like that but
just for learning purposes it just it's
it's a really interesting book on the
view of Jesus and just read that and and
see what you think I would I would
really be interested to see what what
you get out of it what you get out of it
and what you think
man
yeah yeah yeah okay okay he has it so uh
which one you want me to go to First
we're gonna the the first we're gonna
scroll down we're gonna scroll all of
them so this is NIV
um Jesus gave him the answer verily
truly I tell you the son can do nothing
by himself he can only do what he sees
the father doing because whatever the
father does the son also does
all right let's go down to let's go to
King James because he likes the King
James
all right there it is then answered
Jesus and said unto them verily verily I
say unto you the son can do nothing of
himself but what he see it the father do
for
for what things for what
for whatsoever he doeth these also do
what the sun likewise
and so you're also going to get just
different little English variations of
this but it's all the same
yeah well then I you see how I kind of
struggled to get that out when I read
the keychains
but no when you're learning something
we've got to do something it's good to
struggle for it you're right you're
right you're absolutely right man you're
absolutely right so so listen
so and going to these to these verses
right and if we're going to be honest if
we're going to be honest and
you know just take the verses in their
context
we see we see what Jesus taught being
the Son of God who judges who gives life
to whoever he wants and who can do
whatever the father does he never works
alone never does anything separate from
the father but always works with the
father in everything that they do
and we see that that's not an Islamic
teaching right that doesn't go in Islam
with Islam that's like that would
actually like be shirk right that would
be Association according to Islam so
according to the Bible if we're reading
the Bible we read this we can we can
have an interesting practice bro yeah
it's a very interesting message
it gets it gets crazier a matter of fact
hold on man it actually gets even more
crazy so notice how
notice how Jesus says um
he said in verse 21 he says for as the
father raises the dead and gives them
life so also the son gives life to whom
he Wills right he's saying he could do
the same thing God does and then he says
yeah
like uh um what did that verse say
please read it yeah I read it again for
as the father raises the dead and gives
them life
so also the son gives life to whom he
Wills
so where did I get this verse from that
it says Jesus gives life to the dead by
the permission of the father like I read
it somewhere but I can't tell you
exactly where it was
um
uh yeah no there's not a verse that says
that specifically
but uh can you share my screen brother
yeah
yeah there's no verse that says that he
raises a little bit further down
and it says here
for as the father has life in himself so
he has also granted the son also to have
life in himself and he has given him
authority to execute judgment because he
is the son of man dude do not Marvel at
this for an hour is coming when all who
are in the tombs will hear his voice and
come out and those who have done good to
the resurrection of life and those who
are done evil to the resurrection of
evil so Jesus is basically saying here
as well that that hour is coming that
they will hear his voice and then he
will judge them right
so so we were and I'm gonna keep this up
I'm gonna keep this your screen up
so if we were to we're looking at
Jesus's words
um I hope I'm saying that right we're
looking at Jesus's words let me ask you
this from an Islamic perspective
who is the one
who judges at the hour and who will
raise the dead on the day of judgment
who is that
only the father bro right only God and
so if Jesus is saying that I'm the one
who will judge on the day of judgment
and it's my voice who who will raise the
dead and I'm the one who will send them
to heaven for eternal life or send them
to hell then who is Jesus claiming to be
he's claiming to be the Big Daddy in
this verse bro
honest man I've got to be honest man but
like this is really blowing my mind man
because I've never read this anywhere
man right right it says
what did they say like uh he he's the
the ultimate judge yes so he says that
the father has given him judgment right
so the father judges no one but has
given all judgment to the son so the son
is going to be the one judging right and
he says that at this hour at the hour
at the hour this is the hour this is the
hour that Jesus says like only the
father has knowledge and it's it's and
it says here and he has given him
authority to execute judgment because he
is the son of man so it's saying that
Jesus he's the one doing all of this and
then it says do not Marvel at this
for an hour is coming when when all who
are in the tombs will hear his voice and
come out and those who have done good to
the resurrection of life and those who
have done evil to the resurrection of
judgment so Kumi when you stand before
the judge
who's that judge in the Islamic
worldview
the father bro
also in the Jewish worldview it's always
the father it's always gone God almighty
so it's always God Almighty of course
right nothing nothing or nobody with God
almighty singular
so so this shows that Jesus
is claiming to be God almighty
along with the father
so what pathogens is this this is very
interesting yeah this is this is John
chapter five bro this is the same verse
this is the same chapter bro every
Muslim quotes this every you know you
you ever hear Muslims always quote John
5 30 where he said I'm about to I'm
about to show you where you are about to
quote yeah where it says I can do I can
do nothing of my of my own as I hear I
judge and my judgment is judged because
I do not seek my own will but the will
of him who sent me so that's where
Muslims would believe that Jesus
submitted his will and that's where they
would try to prove he's a Muslim yeah
that's what I would believe too but like
uh isn't it like guys isn't this like a
a paradox like yeah in the front it says
like he's the ultimate judge oh it's
gone keep it up Chris keep it up
it says like it's he's the ultimate
judge and then uh when you scroll down
it says like all of myself can do
nothing so like do you understand so he
even says that remember he says that
even in the beginning remember we read
verse 19 he already said that he doesn't
do anything by himself he says truly
truly I say to you the son could do
nothing of himself but only what he sees
the father doing for whatever the father
does the son does the same thing right
so this is showing you it's not talking
about his inability to do something like
he's like he doesn't have the power he's
not able it's he's saying that he
doesn't work alone he never does
anything without the father and the
father doesn't do anything without the
son they are always working together in
everything they do so that's what Jesus
is talking about
you know so he just told us that he's
all-powerful because he just said that
whatever the father Can Do I can do the
son can do it the same exact way
so he says that he's all powerful
because the father's all-powerful but he
says that he does nothing of himself he
doesn't do anything by himself and
neither does the Father the father does
nothing by himself he says the father
shows the son all things that he does so
everything the father does the son is
involved everything the son does the
father is involved they are this is
always this is always like from his
birth to to everything everything
we're talking about God man
we're talking about God it's it's his
his nature and his and his uh Majesty is
so far beyond anything that we can ever
imagine
that's something I agree with Muslims on
I'm sorry
oh you got a call
but it's okay
it's okay uh drop follow me so we could
talk oh yeah oh he had to go I gotta
quit
but yeah
that was fun
God bless that Muslim brother if he's
watching still if he still can hear us I
hope that you come back and we can
continue the conversation man I don't
think that he received a phone call that
he needed to leave the app for I think
that uh something hit him a little hard
at that point
oh my God logic
[Music]